hello welcome to this video crs 64 can i
play let's play something else they are
the Toria tech how to play that usually
written let's vary a little bit and see
what happens and c5 think blank and one
usually takes and goes here just for
quick development yeah and maybe g5 and
night eh okay talk about mysterious
moves King age seven hmm I could have
done that anyway huh okay let's just go
back there is pretty awkward and five
Wow
just wow so he gives me and that's
square just like that it's nice
d one looks like the most natural move
in this position okay so 95 is not
working yet night each form looks
attractive actually trying to get the
light squared Bishop and now let's try
yes should've thought that for one
moment if I teak now we can take with
the pawn which is then I have f4 though
yeah it should be pretty okay I believe
it takes with the pawn f4 now yeah it
looks good I mean head taking age five I
didn't want a scenario where move the
night and eagles 'if I've I mean this is
very risky but I didn't want to allow it
in the first place and came this looks
pretty awful you for poorness um yeah
very very weak gets to e to take you for
next
yeah that simple opening proved to be
very effective so Bishop to d3 warm this
first made him okay I should have played
Bishop to d3 ok now ok it's not a big
deal but it would have been better to
keep the Queen's on playing for check
made
so maybe go here protect f4 check pretty
bad end game still even though I would
have liked to as I said keep Queens on
and play for made
check some g4 base mate around the
corner check checkmate ok so jumpy
pretty much killed himself there King
age 7 and f5 this is pretty suicidal I
think I mean blacken in this position he
can take and and play something and
something normal and black is perfectly
fine I think he has netted the bishop
pair and should be at least equal I
guess it's equal I why does them
immensely solid but if anybody is more
comfortable it's black but this is just
terrible frankly it just weeks we
conserve the position so much I mean
everything is weak now the King side the
eeo everything on the e-file is weak and
so on and b6 and I'm right here this is
probably close to winning on 1.4 and Kim
and back and now a bishop a6 is also a
good move
yeah whether this isn't bad right there
for ya 1.6 is also pretty okay yea my
queen f3 you was a good move then Bishop
d3 yeah anyway I mean this is this any
game and check is this really pretty
simple still effing much the bad minor
piece better looks and so on so it's
just a matter of deciding among
alternatives that are all winning yeah
well that f5 and so on now that it's
just weakening weakening kind of
position far too much okay well thanks
for watching